the games industry has had 6,000 people
laid off with over a 100 rounds of
layoffs already in 2023 and this is
probably only going to get worse with
the Xbox Activision Blizzard merger
actually underway now generally mergers
are when people are the most likely to
get laid off comany with the highest
impact was of course Unity next up was
epic Amazon embracer group Electronic
Arts Sega Game Loft CD project and
Microsoft the console Market was hit
hardest at 32% Indies was second at
18.9% online games were third at 6 16%
and Publishers were fourth at 12% worth
noting the mobile market was the
absolute lowest with only one mobile
Studio having layoffs at all this
website which I would highly recommend
you check out if you want more
information is called videogame
layoffs.com and they actually break down
exactly who the studios were the date
the number of people affected and who
their parent company is which I think is
definitely worth looking into thankfully
this is happening alongside a lot of
Studios unionizing which hopefully will
prevent this kind of thing from
happening so readily in the future